¿Alguna vez os habéis parado a
pensar qué le hace falta a un
país para ser considerado
una gran potencia mundial?
Y a colación de esta pregunta: ¿Vosotros pensáis
que Rusia es una gran potencia mundial? O mejor
dicho, ¿Pensáis que más allá de su arsenal
nuclear Rusia cuenta con los ingredientes
necesarios para ser considerada como tal? ¿Hasta
dónde es capaz de proyectar su influencia?
Y, ojo, porque a pesar de todo lo que hemos visto
en la frontera ruso-ucraniana la
respuesta no es nada sencilla.
Son muchos los factores que entran en juego,
pero para ostentar el título de superpotencia
parece claro que hacen falta tres cosas:
Primero: Capacidad de
intervención y disuasión militar:
Segundo: Influencia política e influencia
en los organismos internacionales;
Y tercero: capacidad económica.
La pregunta por tanto es: ¿cumple la
Rusia de Vladimir Putin estos criterios?
(En términos militares la Federación
Rusa es claramente una superpotencia.
Hablamos de la primera potencia por número
de ojivas nucleares desplegadas, casi 1.500.
Además, Rusia cuenta con
unas fuerzas armadas grandes,
relativamente bien equipadas y sobre
todo, apoyadas por un enorme complejo
industrial-militar. Y aunque no alcancen
tecnológicamente el nivel de desarrollo de
occidente si se puede decir que
cuentan con armamento avanzado.
En segundo lugar, la influencia política y en
organismos internacionales también la tiene.
Rusia es uno de los cinco miembros permanentes
en el Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU que tienen
derecho a veto. El mismo estatus que tienen
Estados Unidos, China, Reino Unido y Francia.)
Sin embargo, cuando hablamos de capacidad
económica o influencia política directa
más allá de su área de influencia
geográfica, entonces la cosa cambia.
Rusia no tiene capacidad para castigar
con sanciones a terceros países,
no cuenta con aliados importantes que puedan
seguir sus directrices y tampoco puede
emplear técnicas de guerra económica.
Además, podemos contar con los dedos de una mano
los países que hoy por hoy aceptan
el liderazgo político de Moscú.
Ahora bien, no penséis ni por un instante que
pretendemos descubrir la pólvora, para nada.
En el Kremlin y el propio presidente ruso, son
perfectamente conscientes de esta realidad,
o más bien de esta debilidad. Y precisamente
por este motivo llevan años tratando de tejer
su propia red de países aliados. Países que
le den a Rusia influencia internacional,
capacidad de liderar y acceso a nuevos mercados.
[Y, ojo, porque no hablamos de China. La relación
chino-rusa es muy importante, fundamental,
para el Kremlin, pero en Moscú son perfectamente
conscientes de que en esa relación Rusia no es
el país líder. China les apoyará cuándo y cómo a
la propia China le venga bien. Ni más ni menos.]
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo lograrlo? ¿Cómo puede
un país como Rusia tratar de construir
esa red de aliados? ¿Hasta dónde
llegan los tentáculos de Moscú? ¿Qué
herramientas utiliza Vladimir Putin
para expandir la influencia rusa?
Pues… Veréis, desde que asumió la presidencia
en 1999, una de las obsesiones del presidente
ruso ha sido llegar a controlar
y rodearse de los oligarcas que
manejan las grandes empresas del
país, en especial las energéticas.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Putín lo ha logrado. La
mayoría de las grandes empresas del país
responden directamente a los intereses
del estado. Y lo hacen hasta tal punto
que frecuentemente se convierten en la punta de
lanza de la mismísima política exterior rusa.
Hablamos, querida comunidad, de un modelo
que tiene como cimientos los favores,
los chantajes y los privilegios de todo
tipo. Prácticamente podemos decir que el
modelo de gobernanza rusa se basa en
algo así como en el toma y daca. En
un juego de favores acordado en un
despacho con las puertas cerradas.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo vamos a
ver como el presidente ruso aprovecha el control
que tiene sobre los grandes oligarcas para
expandir la influencia rusa en el extranjero.
Esta es la espada menos
conocida de la diplomacia rusa.
¡Atentos!
1(OLIGARCAS, LA MANO DE PUTIN)
Pongámonos en perspectiva. La caída
de la Unión Soviética vino seguida de una
etapa de crisis y descomposición política
que alimentó un sueño, casi una obsesión,
entre buena parte de la población rusa:
Recuperar la grandeza, el poder
y su influencia en el mundo.
Porque, amigos, la prosperidad económica,
la buena marcha de las empresas o las
oportunidades profesionales son para muchos
ciudadanos rusos objetivos secundarios.
Lo primero de todo, la prioridad número 1,
es la fuerza, la influencia, el
poder de la madre patria Rusia.
¿Y sabéis qué? Desde su llegada al poder las
políticas de Putín han tenido, exactamente,
esa misma perspectiva. La fortaleza nacional
por encima de cualquier otra cuestión.
Pero, claro, teniendo en cuenta todas las
limitaciones económicas que tiene el país,
la pregunta, la gran pregunta
es, ¿cómo demonios lograrlo?
¿Cómo conseguir influencia frente
a los mismísimos Estados Unidos?
Pues amigos, lo que el gobierno
de Putin ha hecho ha sido,
ni más ni menos que intentar
pescar precisamente en todos
aquellos países que no suscitan mucho
interés para las otras grandes potencias.
Un buen ejemplo reciente lo podemos
encontrar en… Agarraos a la silla…
En el último gran fracaso de la
política exterior norteamericana.
Por supuesto, me estoy refiriendo
al Emirato Islámico de Afganistán.
A día de hoy uno de los países más pobres,
inestables y convulsos de todo el mundo que
ahora Rusia ha fijado en su línea de tiro.
S (El terrorismo, el yihadismo
así como algun que otro proyecto
energético han hecho que Moscú mire
directamente país de los talibanes.
Entre otras cosas porque una de las cosas que
más le aterroriza a Moscú es que este país se
convierta en un epicentro de yihadismo,
en un base de operaciones para grupos
radicales . No olvidemos que Rusia tiene
un problema creciente con esta cuestión.
Gran parte de la antigua de la Unión Soviética
se ha convertido en terreno fértil para la
radicalización yihadista y de hecho, en Rusia
no solo viven más de 20 millones de musulmanes
sino que este llegó a ser el país que más
combatientes extranjeros aportó al ISIS)
Pues bien, con todo esto en mente,
tras la huida de Estados Unidos,
Moscú sintió la necesidad de ganar
influencia así como monitorizar y
vigilar de cerca lo que ocurre en
el Emirato Islámico de Afganistán.
Pues bien, para lograrlo el gobierno de Putin
ha echado mano de su agenda de oligarcas amigos.
Oligarcas que tienen nombres
y apellidos… Y hablamos sobre
todo de uno que destaca por encima de
todos los demás: Yevgeny Prigozhin.
Este hombre, es propietario, - tachan,
tachan - de los restaurantes favoritos
del presidente ruso, motivo por el cual
se le conoce como el Chef de Putin.
Amigos, Prigozhin es un estrecho aliado de
Putin y dedica una parte de su fortuna a
financiar actividades políticas
y paramilitares en el exterior.
Hablamos de uno de los actores más poderosos
en los círculos políticos de Rusia. Uno de
los oligarcas más importantes del país. Ni
gas, ni petróleo, ni carbón. Restaurantes.
Bueno, restaurantes…. Y también mercenarios.
Yevgeniy Prigozhin es algo así como un
representante del Kremlin en la sombra.
El tipo al que se le confían las misiones que
el gobierno ruso no quiere que sean oficiales.
Un personaje que goza prácticamente del monopolio
a la hora proyectar las ambiciones de
Rusia hacia Oriente Medio y África.
A cambio, claro está, de
perseguir su propio beneficio.
Es un win-win en toda regla.
Ahora bien, una pregunta que seguro,
seguro muchos os estáis haciendo es, ¿Cómo
trabaja? ¿Cómo proyecta su influencia?
Pues veréis, Prigozhin es
el creador del Grupo Wagner.
(El Grupo Wagner es una organización paramilitar
que cuenta con una red internacional de
mercenarios y negocios poco limpios que operan
en países donde no nos gustaría ir de vacaciones.
El Grupo Wagner ha desplegado fuerzas
paramilitares en países como Siria,
Libia, Sudán e incluso se les relaciona
con la invasión de Ucrania de 2014.
Y no solo eso. También se
les atribuye intervenciones
en países amigos de Rusia para
sofocar protestas pro-democracia,
realizar todo tipo de campañas de desinformación
y operaciones de bandera falsa. Este grupo fue,
por ejemplo, acusado de interferir en
las elecciones estadounidenses de 2016
Incluso, se dice que este grupo también se
dedica a la extracción de oro y diamantes,
muy probablemente de minas ilegales.)
Vamos, que no son precisamente una ONG
ni una empresa a la que le preocupe
la Responsabilidad Social Corporativa, los
criterios ESG o cualquier de esas cuestiones.
Por supuesto, Yevgeniy Prigozhin
es uno de los oligarcas sobre los
que pesan sanciones de Estados Unidos.
Y sí, podríamos llegar a decir que Rusia
tiene algo así como dos ministerios de asuntos
exteriores y dos ministerios de defensa. Están
Lavrov, Shoigú como ministros formales y Prigozhin
como el encargado de operar en la sombra.
Pues, el caso es que este oligarca ruso
es también el principal financiador de
la Fundación para la Protección de
los Valores Nacionales, la FZNC.
(La Fundación para la Protección
de los Valores Nacionales es una
organización con presencia en varios
países de África y Asia Central.
En el caso de Afganistán, su hombre de confianza
en el terreno, Maxim Shugaley, fue una de las
primeras personas en llegar a Kabul después
de que los talibanes se hicieran con el poder.
Shugaley controla una red política dependiente de
la FZNC que busca encontrar áreas de cooperación
en materia de seguridad y también económicas
entre los talibanes y Rusia. Buscar áreas
de cooperación y, por supuesto, estar al
tanto de todo lo que ocurra en el país.)
Y, ojo, porque no hablamos de cualquier tipo
sino de uno muy experimentado. Por ejemplo,
llegó a ser encarcelado en Libia desde
julio de 2019 hasta diciembre de 2020
por haberse reunido con Saif al-Islam
Gaddafi, un hijo del ex-líder libio,
para animarle a que diera el
salto a la primera línea política.
Ahora bien, ¿qué quieren exactamente Putin,
Prigozhin y Shugaley de los talibanes?
M Pues bien. Una de las consecuencias
directas que ha tenido el ascenso al
poder de los talibanes es el
aislamiento internacional del
país. Son muy pocos los países que
quieren tener lazos con Afganistán.
Así que si los talibanes quieren obtener dinero,
armas, energía o información para consolidar su
poder, ¿Qué mejor que recurrir al
oso ruso? El pasado, pasado está.
Pero, ¿Qué puede sacar Rusia de un lugar tan
inhóspito, empobrecido y desolado como Afganistán?
Pues convertirse en el actor extranjero más
influyente de todo el país. Y os preguntaréis,
¿Para qué demonios quiere esa
influencia en un país tan desolado?
Pues por ejemplo para impedir que
Afganistán se convierta en una base
de operaciones para grupos yihadistas
que Moscú considera una amenaza.
Pero eso no es todo. Moscú también
persigue lo que podríamos denominar
como objetivos de geoestrategia económica. e
Ahí estarían los enormes yacimientos de
minerales estratégicos, como el litio, que tiene
Afganistán pero también hablamos de proyectos
estratégicamente tan importantes como este:
Lo que veis en pantalla es el proyecto TAPI,
un enorme gasoducto que una vez se complete
permitirá transportar enormes cantidades de gas
desde Turkmenistán hasta la India y Pakistán.
Hablamos de por lo menos 33.000 millones de
metros cúbicos de gas anuales en una primera fase.
(El régimen talibán desplegará
30.000 soldados para reanudar
las obras del proyecto del gasoducto
TAPI - Pipeline technology Journal)
Pero eso no es todo.
Fijaos de nuevo en el mapa.
Afganistán podría llegar a convertirse
para la India y Pakistán - dos países
que suman más de 1.600 millones de habitantes,
el 20% de la población mundial - en lo que durante
años Ucrania ha sido para la Unión Europea.
Un enclave estratégico indispensable
para recibir un enorme caudal de
gas natural y petróleo desde los
ricos yacimientos de Asia Central.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Los rusos llevan años
queriendo formar parte de este negocio. Fijaos.
(Rusia interesada en participar en la construcción
del gasoducto TAPI - Lavrov
- Business Turkmenistan)
Y la pregunta es, ¿por qué
diantres le interesa tanto
a Rusia? Pues fundamentalmente por 2 motivos:
En primer lugar, Rusia es un enorme exportador de
petróleo y gas natural. Participar en la que puede
llegar a ser una de las rutas más importantes del
mundo reforzaría mucho su influencia energética.
Y en segundo lugar, de consolidarse esta ruta,
Rusia podría llegar a utilizarla en el futuro
para exportar su propio gas y petróleo. Y ojo,
porque las estimaciones apuntan a que la India
devorará gas y petróleo durante los próximos años.
Y creedme cuando os digo que los rusos están
como locos por buscar clientes alternativos
a las economías europeas pero también
a China. La ruta afgana y la conexión
con la India podrían ser una vía para
conseguir un nuevo cliente gigantesco.
En esta línea el gasoducto TAPI podría
ser ampliado y eventualmente conectado
a los campos de extracción de gas que Rusia y
Kazajistán están desarrollando en el mar Caspio.
(Hablamos de los campos de Tsentralnoye e
Imashevskoye, una joint venture entre el
principal productor de gas kazajo,
la KazMunayGas National Company,
y un consorcio ruso, formado por Lukoil y Gazprom.
Ambos países tienen una participación
en el proyecto del 50%, y para Gazprom,
por ejemplo, estos campos serán su
mayor apuesta en el Mar Caspio.)
¿Quién iba a pensar que un territorio tan
paupérrimo y desolado como Afganistán podría
ser potencialmente tan importante? Pues para
asegurarse de que todo está bajo control ahí
están los oligarcas rusos montando sus redes
de influencia y vigilancia por todo el país.
A cambio los talibanes reciben
armas, asesoramiento, energía,
suministros de diverso tipo e incluso llegado
el caso dinero. El paquete completo de Rusia.
Ahora bien, no penséis ni por un instante
que este es el único ejemplo que vamos
a poder encontrar. Basta con echar
un vistazo al continente africano y
también a Latinoamérica para encontrar
mucha actividad por parte de Moscú.
Atentos.
F2(EL CATÁLOGO RUSO)
Sí, la influencia de Estados Unidos y sus
aliados occidentales es muy pero que muy
grande, pero también es cierto que en algunos
lugares es mucho más limitada que en otros.
No es ningún secreto y es algo de lo que
ya os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
La influencia de China en África se
ha disparado en los últimos años.
Mediante inversiones, construcción de
infraestructuras, acuerdos comerciales
o transferencia de tecnología el
gobierno chino ha ganado mucha
influencia y también nuevos clientes y
nuevos proveedores para sus empresas.
Pues bien, en cierto modo Rusia está intentando
hacer algo muy similar. Claro que por mucho que le
pese a Putin Rusia no es China. Moscú no tiene
ni de lejos la cartera tan llena como Pekín.
Así que al Kremlin le ha tocado
buscar otras fórmulas, digamos,
más imaginativas para abrirse paso.
(En el caso de África, Rusia aspira a
convertirse en un importante proveedor
de cereales, medicamentos y energía. En
esta línea, por ejemplo, con más de 7,5
millones de toneladas anuales, Rusia es
ya el mayor exportador de trigo a Egipto,
También quiere aprovechar su amplia
experiencia para impulsar proyectos
mineros y energéticos en países como
Zimbabue, Angola o Burkina Faso.)
¿Os acordáis del bueno de Yevgeny Prigozhin,
“el Chef de Putin”? Pues se conoce que sus
empresas han recibido concesiones para explotar
diamantes y oro en la República Centroafricana.
¿Otro ejemplo? Sergey Ivanov, hijo
del ex-ministro de Defensa ruso,
es el director ejecutivo de Alrosa, una
empresa minera rusa especializada en diamantes.
Porque, amigos, quizás Rusia no tenga tanta
capacidad económica como China o Estados Unidos,
pero sí tiene algo que muchos
gobiernos autocráticos desean:
armas, pocos escrúpulos y mucha experiencia en
materia de inteligencia, represión y seguridad.
Por ejemplo, ¿os acordáis del grupo Wagner
que hemos comentado antes? Pues fijaos.
C1(En los últimos años, se
han desplegado contratistas
del Grupo Wagner en todo Oriente Medio
y África, incluidos Siria, Yemen, Libia,
Sudán, Mozambique, Madagascar, República
Centroafricana y Malí. Se han centrado
principalmente en la protección de las
élites gobernantes y las infraestructuras
críticas. Federica Saini Fasanotti,
analista de Brookings Institution.)
Además los rusos y los chinos son
muy pragmáticos. No preguntan por
cosas como los derechos humanos,
la democracia o el medio ambiente.
Y eso en este tipo de países es una
ventaja a la hora de hacer negocios.
Pues bien, ¿Sabéis qué? El modus operandi es
muy similar al que hemos visto en Afganistán:
Los oligarcas rusos se establecen en el terreno
y buscan acuerdos con los gerifaltes locales.
Gerifaltes que reciben cosas tan importantes para
mantener su poder como acceso al catálogo completo
de la industria militar rusa, con sección
especial de mercenarios, la experiencia,
la tecnología y el Know How que necesiran
para poder explotar sus recursos naturales.
A cambio Rusia consigue influencia
política, nuevos clientes y también,
por supuesto, enriquecer aún más a
los oligarcas cercanos al Kremlin.
Desde Libia hasta Nigeria y desde Etiopía
hasta Mali, durante los últimos años Moscú
ha cerrado más de 20 acuerdos militares a lo
largo y ancho de todo el continente africano.
Algo que le ha permitido a Rusia convertirse
en el mayor exportador de material militar
para África. Para que os hagáis una idea,
su cuota de mercado roza casi el 50%.
N3(13 sep 2021: Rusia está construyendo su
influencia militar en África, desafiando el
dominio estadounidense y francés. CNBC)
(2 octubre de 2021: El plan de Malí
para que mercenarios rusos sustituyan a las tropas
francesas inquieta al Sahel. BBC)
Queridos amigos, amigas, más allá
de Ucrania y los grandes titulares, así es como
Moscú intenta incrementar su influencia política
en el mundo al tiempo que logra nuevos mercados
para sus productos. E incluso más importante,
consigue los dólares que sus empresas militares
necesitan para seguir mejorando sus equipos.
Esta es la fórmula que Rusia utiliza para seguir
teniendo toda la influencia que una superpotencia
necesita. Y en esta fórmula los oligarcas y las
grandes empresas rusas juegan un papel clave.
Allí donde occidente no mira,
China y también Rusia suelen tener
al menos un pie puesto en el terreno.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para
ti. ¿Qué te parece la apuesta rusa por
extender su influencia de la mano
de oligarcas cercanos al Kremlin?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo,
en los comentarios. Y si te ha
gustado este vídeo no olvides darle
like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Una vez más, gracias por estar
ahí. Un saludo, y hasta la próxima.